depuis quelques mois c'est enfin le cas
meghan markle et le prince harry ont
réussi leur émancipation loin du royaume
d'angleterre en s'installant au canada
puis en californie mais avec ce départ
loin de la famille royale le couple a
aussi dit adieu à l'argent de buckingham
si l'ofj aujourd'hui dans une villa de
luxe estimée à 18 millions d'euros il
s'agit là d'un prêt de la part d'une
proche ami de l'animatrice oprah winfrey
le couple serait en réalité dans le
rouge et pourrait bientôt se retrouver
face à d'importantes difficultés
financières
et avec leur train de vie et l'argent
que leur coûte leur protection
rapprochée les factures sont
conséquentes chaque mois pourtant à
l'âge de 30 ans harry aperçu
l'importante héritage de sa maman la
princesse lady di un héritage de 23
millions d'euros aujourd'hui la fortune
du jeune marié est estimé à 40 millions
de livres
mais il faut croire qu'au pays des
palmiers l'argent se dépense bien
facilement
ouais quoi quoi il part dont 40 millions
de livres et avoir des soucis d'arrêt
parce que c'est d'être mal ils font
n'importe quel était leur train de vie
pourrais-tu l'école un personnage cela
pour fermer sous là pour faire deux
stations de métro et prenne un avion ils
prennent un jet et des tarés soldes mais
dites moi c'est plus c'est pas l'accent
anglais là qu'on a c'est non mais je
suis devenu fou non même jean michel
fritz a fait des travaux dans leur
maison
la réaction qui ont été payés par la
couronne
et comme ils ont ils ont déserté la
famille royale l'état m'attend
britannique leur demande de rembourser
les travaux qualité paie bien amusé sur
la fortune elle convient tant qu'ils
sont maintenant qu'ils sont parvenus à
buckingham palace a bien sûr que vous
lire eh ben ils vont avoir
ils vont pas les lâcher et sont même les
verviétois moi je vais vous dire ce qui
va se passer vous revenir avec la valise
on va dire une doublement une main
derrière et l'autre à qu entre les gens
et ils vont se calmer et je peux vous
dire que la reine va y arriver à
l'évasion va me chercher du salami et tu
fais affaire mais selon mes bras mais je
te le dis oui au moins c'est au moins en
partie vrai ce que vous dites pas c'est
sûr ils ont américains n'arrêtent pas de
souligner le fait que harry des primes
complètement juste au niveau de la
voyance vous prenez sur rendez vous la
presse people et meriem c'est tout ce
que j'arrive à la main derrière un
rideau et donc tandis qu'il est
complètement déprimée que megan ne veux
pas retourner en angleterre mais que lui
ça commence vraiment à lui manquer les
étudiants avec l'état de santé de son
père et où bien sûr culpabiliser prince
charles
charlie attendu corona jeu c'est le
pauvre charlie on envoie charly et lulu
d'ailleurs également aussi les brime
modérément commun ils sont hébergés dans
une superbe villa de los angeles le pays
qu'un milliardaire qui est magnifique et
christiane sur nos gardes du corps j'ai
bien écrit mais comme ça n'était pas
bien et avec jacuzzi qui tend pas à moi
je les ai vus c'était des prix mais
toute la soirée
tu veux te dire c'est qu'ils en ont jeté
des boules carrées l'origine c'est adele
c'est intéressant qu'est ce que vous
avez dit j leur voisine c'est adel lâche
on est sûr plus en plus ça n'est pas
morte
non merci